hi guys it's silver right again enough
just been marathoning Haruhi Suzumiya
all or two seasons of the series and the
movie and oh my god you can't even
comprehend all the fields I'm feeling
right now I'm really not in the mood for
this but I've got some silver rat stuff
to do so open up rollercoaster 3 look at
this was like [ __ ] did I built this so I
guess I'll just continue in this then
ladies and gentlemen
enjoy the time-lapse
all right so that entrance Plaza is
almost finished - well I still have to
finish it next episode so it has already
taken three episodes which is a lot more
than the entrance Plaza for verona
valley and hopefully i can finally start
building some rights next time because I
mean ya are starting to get kind of
tired of this and I'm also going to look
for a Top Spin CFR or something else I
don't know something that looks cool
over there just do place here and have a
nice view of the lake and yeah cool and
I guess they all come together very
nicely
so till next episode